the first photo of Rene Zellweger  playing Judy Garland in the upcoming  biopic judy has been released and the 48  year old actress will have you doing a  double-take oh wow  in the shot Zeller is rocking a brunette  updo and a black off-the-shoulder floral  dress striking Garland  signature singing pose now this won't be  the first time Zellweger has shown off  her vocal chops in a film  [Music]  noxee she portrayed Roxie Hart in the  2002 film adaptation of Chicago which  earned her an Oscar nomination according  to Deadline Judy will take place in 1968  30 years after garland became a  household name as Dorothy in The Wizard  of Oz the film will follow Garland as  she prepares for her sold-out run at the  talk of the town nightclub garland died  not long after June 1969 she had just  turned 47 years old the movie is set to  come out later this year but a specific  date has not been announced  [Music]